John:All right, this is John Kohler with
Growingyourgreens.com with another exciting
episode for you. and what I'm going to do
today is actually I got a special guest on
the show. actually just recently I was at
the 2016 Naturopathic doctors conference here
in Las Vegas, Nevada. I make my way to many
different health food and health conferences
throughout the year, amongst all the other
gardening andheirloomevents that I visit
to keep up to date with what's going on, with
you know, not like traditional medical care,
but what's considered nowadays alternative
or complementary cure.So I go to a lot
of the different talks at the Naturopathic
doctor’s convention and hear a lot of different
speakers and learn about a lot of different
products and supplements and actually new
foods. you know, that they try to say in a
package but then I just, you know, decide
to grow 'em.And I learn about a lot of new
stuff and one of the people who is there,
I interviewed. that's going to come on a little
bit later in this segment.
But before I get into him,I want to share
more about what I'm into and growing in my
garden, and why this is one of the fundamental
keys to my gardening success and one of the
reasons why I personally garden myself. And
what it comes down to for me personally, is
the trace minerals.You know you guys have
heard me talk about it before.Whether you're
going to get it from soil humates, rock dust,
or even you know ocean solids, you know I
want you guys to get the trace minerals into
your garden. Because, number one your plants
will respond.I have seen in my gardens and
many friend’s gardens, when they start adding
the trace minerals,their plants just get
plain healthier.There's something in them
trace minerals, that the plants love. they
get healthier, in turn they take up these
nutrients, these trace minerals inthemselves
and when they make their fruit, such as my
peppers here or they make the leaves, lettuce
or kale or collard greens or Egyptian spinach,
whatever I'm growing, when they make their
leaves, now they take up the inorganic form
of that mineral and basically turn it into
an organic mineral. and when it's in the state
that is taken up into the plant, it basically
changes the polarity or the charge on the
mineral so that we can actually accept it
easily into us. you know just sucking out
a copper penny might get you some copper,
but you're not going to have a high level
of uptake because it's the wrong charge on
it. And that's why I like to get my minerals
from food.
Furthermore, I want to go into this, you know
because a lot of guys haven't seen this before.
it's actually a Senate document. the Senate
document is from 1936.Document 264 74th
Congress,2nd session, and it's entitled
'The modern miracle men'.This was presented
to Congress, way back then. And Congress and
the government and people have known about
this since that time.What it basically is,
it relates to proper food mineral balances
by Dr. Charles Northern, reprinted from Cosmopolitan
June 1936.Alright, so basically it starts
like this:do you know that most of us today
are suffering from certain dangerous dietary
deficiencies which cannot be remedied until
the depleted stores from which our foods come
are brought into proper mineral balance.The
alarming fact, is that foods, fruits and vegetables
and grains now being raised on millions of
acres of land that are no longer contains
enough of certain needed minerals are starving
us no matter how much of them we eat. this
is back in the 1930s. And let me tell you,
through actually studies and reports I've
seen from the U.S.D.A. minerals in the food,
over the years, are just declining and declining
and declining. nowadays they're at an all
time low.And this is because commercial
industry is not putting back all the various
amounts of trace minerals back in the soil.
They're focused on three main minerals N,
P, K.And then along with the many, conventional,
synthetic made fertilizers along with the
N P K, they're shoving in, in many cases without
telling people, small amounts of minerals.But
these are not the minerals that we want, these
are the heavy, heavy metal minerals that actually
they're just dumping you know.The answer
to pollution is not dilution, or I don't know,
something like that. but anyway, they're diluting
the heavy metals that toxic- that industry
is creating in fertilizers, that then grow
to grow food for cattle and also for us.So
I want you guys to step out of that system
and grow your own mineral rich food.
anyways you guys could look up this Senate
document, but I think if I go to the end I
could sum it up.I mean, it basically talks
a lot about, a lot about a different about
a lot of different things and here's one of
the points: healthy plants mean healthy people,
said he, we can't raise a strong race on weak
soil.Why don't you try mending the deficiencies
in your farm and growing some more minerals
in your crops?So then they go on and basically
they planted celery with trace minerals and
they found that it had at least I think twice
as much minerals as celery not grown with
the trace minerals, also it stored longer.And
it was healthier to eat, going on further
in the book, I mean I want you guys to actually
look up this book. I'll put a link down below
to this.So you guys could look it up and
read the whole thing yourself, to learn about
all this stuff, because I mean I was exposed
to this, must be like twenty years ago now.It
says a famous nutrition authority recently
said, one sure way to end the American people
susceptibility to infection, is to supply
through food based ration or iron, copper
and other metals. an organism requirements
may so utilize these elements, as to produce
immunity from infection quite beyond anything
we're able to produce artificially by our
present method of immunization. you can't
make up that deficiency by using patent medicine.So
think about that.What is he really saying
there. I mean I kind of feel like my English
instructor when he's reading Shakespeare and
stuff and I like, really didn't understand
what all that stuff was about Shakespeare
and all this stuff. but I understand this:basically
he's saying, that if we have you know, food
that's deficient, we're not getting all their
trace minerals. we're going to get higher
levels of diseases and you know even the latest
medicine, immunizations or whatever, is not
going to fix that efficiency. the deficiency
isn’t a deficiency from a vaccine, or from
a drug, which always have side effects, which
are just undesired effects. but the deficiency
is because we're not eating the proper foods
anymore.And this is what I'm really so passionate
about these days.I mean I guess at the end,
I'll sum it up, last line of this booklet.
it is simpler to cure sick soils, than sick
people. which shall we choose? this was back
in 1936 man.What do they choose?Well industry,
the government, whomever is in charge, chose
the path of least resistance,I suppose,
which is the path of financial interests,
big corporations, companies making a lot of
money and you know making chemical fertilizers
that could be soldafter the World War. and
they had all these excess, you know factories
making you know bombs, now they could make
fertilizer out of them and make money. and
so I don't know,things didn't go exactly
as, as I would have liked. and trace minerals
are really important, and what I want to do
next for you isactually turn this into an
interview with Dr. Joel Wallach actually.
He is the man, who enlightened me originally,
about the importance of trace minerals, and
how to get them into our bodies. so I see
Dr. Wallach pretty much every year, at the
Naturopathic Doctor’s Convention and this
year I decided to interview him for you guys,
to pass on his very important words of wisdom.
because he's been doing this even longer than
I have. so let's go ahead and get into the
interview with Dr. Wallach.
So now I have the pleasure of interviewing
Dr. Joel Wallach, and he's the expert on minerals
that I've learned about, you know back in
what is it, the 1990s. there was a cassette
tape, this kind of dates a little bit,that
went around called Dead Doctors Don't Lie.And
this is the man that made that tape, and he
is the one that basically enlightened me,
about the importance of trace minerals in
our diets and why you should use them to grow
your food, and how they can positively affect
to help your health and your plants health.So
I want to just get Dr. Wallach today on, to
basically share with you guys the importance
of using trace minerals in your garden, because
if you go down to standard big box store,
and you get some fertilizer package or conventional
fertilizer, you know synthetic fertilizer
has like ten ten ten, but those are three
main minerals in there. and you know we need
a lot more than that.So I'm not going to
take the show away from Dr. Wallach, we want
to get his expert opinion here. so Dr. Wallach,
why is using just three standard minerals
which is what most of conventional and even
a lot of organic farming focuses on?
Dr. Wallach:Well John, first of all thank
you for asking me to speak with you.Plants
only need three minerals.All vertebrates,
including human beings require sixty.That's
why we have this discrepancy, and we see other
minerals from putting our wood ash from our
wood stoves into the garden, and also the
spring floods that leaves silt when the floodwater
recedes, we plough that in. and that renews
the minerals in the soil. but once you get
electricity, there's no more wood ashes going
into the garden, and because we have hydroelectric
plants, there is no more flooding and so there's
no more silt left in the spring to plough
back in the soil and renews the minerals in
the soil. and so in the agricultural industry,
and as you know I'm a veterinarian, as well
as a naturopathicphysician, so in the agricultural
industry, we make surethecheapest, most
economical and most efficient way to get the
minerals into our dairy cows and our beef
cows and our chickens and pigs and things,
is to feed it to them,give it to them.Thelittle
alfalfa pellets, aren't just alfalfa, it's
corn and alfalfa and maybe some wheat and
maybe some rice.Certainly there's ninety
cents of nutrients, sixty minerals, sixteen
vitamins, from amino acids, three fatty acids
put in there.And we put them in the animal
feed because we don't have insurance for them.
and they get this and it increases fertility,
it increases longevity, increases live births
and eliminates birth defects, increases production-
instead of having a cow give you half a quart
of milk or they're getting a gallon and a
half, instead of chickens laying eggs at three
a week, they'll lay three eggs a day and so
on. and so by giving the animals the 90 essential
nutrients, which include all the trace minerals
which are cofactors, enzymes, and hormones
working in the body, all vertibrateswhat happens
is you're maximizing the genetic potential
of that human being, or that animal, has for
health, fending off disease,longevity, production.
and this is the piece we're missing as humans.
and humans, medical doctors will say, oh just
eat well. you'll get everything you need.
No, because plants might only have three minerals,
they don't make minerals.If you put three
minerals in the soil to make the plant happy,
they'll make good seeds for the next generation,
but you're not getting what you need.That's
why there's blue zones, according to Dan Buettner,
for Natural Geographic. and he called them
blue zones, because he's circling with a blue
crayon right on the map, very scientific.
but these are the longest lived of peoples
on earth and by dumb luck they live in places
that have more than sixty minerals in their
soil and they're still using wood stoves.
These are all third world cultures,longest
lived peoples on Earth according to National
Geographic. because they still have wood stoves,
they are putting the wood ashes in the garden,
so that the plant doesn't need more than three
minerals but they'll suck them all up. and
so then when you eat the plant has been fertilized
with the wood ashes, with the plant minerals,
right, because wood ashes are only actually
the minerals the tree soaks up. and so that's
why the longest lived people of the third
world cultures, minerals, minerals, minerals.
it eliminates all birth defects; all birth
defects are caused by nutritional deficiencies
in the embryos. there's no birth defects are
passed on by genetics, none.That's an overreach
of the science of genetics/ Genetics will
determine your hair color, your eye color,
your skin color, your gender, boy/girl kind
of thing, and it will tell your liver cells
to make liver cells, was repairing itself,
to
John:Wow. Yeah I mean, I went to this talk
earlier, I mean, this guy's a wealth of knowledge.
I want to this talk earlier onepigenetics,
which is basically the expression of your
genes. so you have genes and if you have nutrient
deficiencies, like especially in the trace
minerals, then your, you may be sicker, a
lot of different things could happen, because
the expression of your genes is different
than how they should be if you had all the
nutrition in there. Anyways the doctor could
talk for hours about this mineral for this
and this, but I want to get in some more important
information for you guys, like Doctor,you
talked about the wood ashes. Right,so if
my viewers that are gardening, if they use
wood ashes in their garden,you know, I've
heard things like, you know too many wood
ashes might not be a good thing. but will
they get all the minerals they need from wood
ashes, or should they not guarantee that they're
going to get all the minerals from just using
the wood ashes, should they get maybe another
product?
Dr. Wallach:because there's no guarantee,
because nutritional minerals, John, do not
occur in a uniform blank or on the coast here.
they occur in veins like chocolate and chunky
ice cream, but all swirls and swirls.And
these twenty top longevity cultures, they
by dumb luck, live in places that have all
these minerals. have sixty or more minerals
and so.Rest ones who eat well, they garden
organic gardening and they'll die of ruptured
aneurysm at age thirty-two.That's because
they didn't have the trace minerals in the
soil. the only way to guarantee it, is to
supplement with it, in your mouth or, supplement
your garden with it.Ok. And course, we do
have a product,
We 'll talk about that in a little bit
Dr. Wallach:Yes, and so we have the ability
to do that.And as a result the yield goes
up, the health of the crops goes up, the health
of the land goes up.And it's just one of
those miracles, to increase your yield, time
so many fold.For instance, use our program,
you can take sweet potatoes, which would normally
give you mature sweet potatoes of a quarter
of a pound, they will be twelve, fourteen
pounds, big as a football.And they're sweeter
and more tender than the little ones. and
the same was true with all the fruit and berries,
strawberries, they're huge and they're bright
red all the way through the center, they don't
have that white pulp in the middle kind of
thing. and tomatoes are three times bigger,
same thing is true for animals are fed like
soybeans or hay that are fertilized with these
minerals. their milk production goes up, the
egg production goes up, their weight gain
and beef cattle and pigs goes up, fertility
goes up, survivability of babies goes up,
all their birth defects goes away, all the
white muscle disease,things like mulberry
heart disease in pigs, all those birth defects,
cleft palate, Down syndrome, that all goes
away, cerebropalsy,it all goes away by supplementing
with these trace minerals.
John:yeah, trace minerals are super important.
If you guys watch me for any length of time,
you guys know I'm really on and into the trace
minerals.So Dr., I know there's a lot of
people out there, that say, I don't need to
add to trace minerals to my garden because
my soil is fertile, where I live, and the
minerals are already in there.My plants
grow fine.What would you say to them?
Dr. Wallach:Well the reason why the minerals
are in the plants, is that the plants will
suck them out of the soil, unless you're renewing
those minerals by putting the plant minerals
aka wood ashes in, or leaving in flood silt,
that's coming form places that have the sixty
minerals in it.after a period of six, eight,
ten years, depending on how intense you grow
crops in your garden, there won't be any minerals
left in the garden. your garden will die,
and you'll have to start adding commercial
fertilizer.OK.You must fertilize the
soil, two or three or four times a year depending
on what you're growing, to make it optimal
for the plant and optimal for the man and
animals that are eating those plans.Otherwise
you're not going to guarantee, and I'll give
you an analogy. I think this is a good place
to kind of, end.
Alright.
Dr. Wallach:The analogy goes like this.Let's
say you take your car to a mechanic, and he
say it's time to change the oil. and you say
well, I don't want to spend a lot of money
for six quarts of high grade oil.I want
the cheapest oil.So I can do better than.
Instead of putting six quarts of cheap oil
in your car,I’m going to put six quarts
of dirt from Texas in your car. never mind
there's lots of oil in Texas, there's bound
to be some oil in that dirt from Texas. That'll
take care of your car.Nobody would do that,
even to an old rusted out, dented up car.
You say no, I don't believe that one. But
people believe when doctors say, oh just
eat well you will get everything you need.
What you want to do is take all ninety essential
nutrients, even though you've been putting
these nutrients in the garden, you still want
to supplement. and then what you're getting
from your food is value added. That's one
way to look at it.You do not want to not
supplement. you do not want to not supplement.
and then you supplement the soil.You will
maximize your genetic potential for health
and longevity at that point.
John:Yeah I mean, I totally agree.I don't
want you guys to become deficient.So Dr.,
what's the soil product that you recommend
us?I have some in my house, there's a liquid
and a solid right, I got both of them myself.I've
been using them, the blooming' mineral. So
how can that actually create fertility and
add these very important trace minerals into
some of these gardening, and why do you come
up with this product?
Dr. Wallach:well there's seventy-eight minerals
in this product, seventy-eight minerals, including
all sixty essential minerals at optimal amounts.It's
called Blooming mineral, as you pointed out.
we have in forty pound bags of granules.We
also have it in quart, and fifty-five gallon
drums of the liquid. Depending on how big
your operation is, either use a sprayer or
a spreader. and so you can full your fees
as well as do the granules on the soil.And
so we kind of go through this,we have a
lot of experience and so we can, actually
I’m working on a book, but we do have one
book that kind of covers this. it’s called
"Rare Earths Forbidden Cures".Which you
looked at earlier.And so that one is a very,
very good one, tells what minerals are missing
when you get certain diseases.How the minerals
work.What enzyme system, what hormones require
them to function properly.
John:Awesome, awesome and then I apply these
minerals to my garden like after every growing
season so once a year.You know, I grow two
different cropping, so like a summer crop,
and a winter crop, all I add the minerals
and more compost and create fertility after
every season of planting, because I'm pulling
nutrients out in my plants and I want to put
them back in, and even if I'm adding more
than
the plant are
putting out, that's
a
good thing. that's like putting money in the
bank. versus like taking money out of the
bank and being withdrawn and overbalancing,
getting like you know them fees right.You
don't want to over pull from the soil.
So. actually Dr. Wallach got a call and he
had to take off, so I couldn't get to finishmy
interview with him.So I'm kind of sad, but
at least I'm glad I got what I got on tape
for you guys.So you guys could hear it.So
you guys could learn the importance of the
trace minerals, you know, not only do I add
trace minerals in for my plants, which some
people still you know, fail to realize that
plants really need more than just three N.P.
K. or maybe fifteen or sixteen minerals.But
I mean if nature, God, whomever put all these
minerals on the earth, and they should be
in the soil. then if they're not there,I
mean then, then it's not we're not growing,
or going according with nature.So here's
the thing, like the soils are getting pulled
out, the nutrients, the minerals are not getting
put back in.So there's basically two solutions,
right.WhenI learned about Dr. Wallach,
I learned that Dead Doctors Don't Lie tape,
and he was trying to sell a colloidal mineral
supplement, which you know I took at the time.But
I tried to figure out likewise, like John,
you could take a supplement, you could buy
a supplement for the rest of your life, but
what's even better than buying a supplement?Hey,
I want to eat foods that are mineralized.
and at the time I wasn't actually growing
my food. I was getting all my food from the
grocery store, from the farmer's market, and
even most farmers unfortunately, do not add
trace minerals. the majority of people, even
home gardeners, don't add trace minerals,
except if you're one of my long term viewers
and watch me and and trust in what I say,
and trust in the experts that I have on for
you guys, because I'm just sharing what I've
learned over the years, all these years that
have been really important to me right. and
I don't want to lose my life, you know, from
something that I could have prevented. right
I don't want to be my mistake right.And
I'm just sharing what I know and that's why
I make these videos
So, anyways I just cited that, you know I
could take these colloidal minerals, that's
pretty good, but I don't want to be hooked
on a supplement for the rest of my life. so
I want to like, grow my own high quality food
and eat food predominantly out of my garden
that has all these trace minerals in there,
in amounts that nature would require. So that's
why I started gardening and growing my food.I
took out my front yard, my front lawn, and
started growing. I raised a bed of vegetable
gardens, I was, like I think nine years ago
now. before that I was growing in the periphery
of my yard, and that's really good right?And
I know a lot of you guys are growing with
the trace minerals, and that's great, also.And
there's many different types of the kind,
actually Dr. Wallach himself actually has
a company.It's actually called the Youngevity,
it’s right here, this is one of his products
right here.That's the Dr. Wallach right
there. and basically this is, this is the
blooming minerals product.This is a soil
revitalizer and this is a OMRI certified for
use in organic farming.This is a small jar
full, It's two and a half pounds.It's actually
kind of expensive, they have a bigger bag
which is a much better deal in my opinion.This
is the one that you will want to buy, if you
want to revitalize your soil with up to seventy-six
different minerals in there. and if we open
it, and it has a list of all of them on the
back.But this is the one he formulated,
he put together andhe's recommending. And
so if you want to trust the doctor,that's
what I would recommend to you guys.And
so I have a link down below, if you want to
purchase this product.And I'll just show
you guys what it looks like. basically it
looks like this, and what this is in my opinion
and I don't really know exactly for sure,
because I'm not a soil microbiologist or all
this stuff, but it looks like soil humates
to me, right.And soil humates are commonly
available for actually a lot less than what
this is being sold for, but those soil humates
may not be organic approved and you know they
may be of varying quality. So I'm sure he
checks each and every batch to ensure he's
getting some of the best stuff because you're
also paying more for it.So yeah, so besides
just this stuff the blooming minerals or soil
humates, you could also use things like a
rock dust, and not all rock dust is created
equal.I'm not really going to get into rock
here.Be sure to click some of the links
below, where I’ll have a link to my playlists
about rock dust, where you can learn more
about it. I'm also the ocean solids or ocean
minerals and also put links down below, to
some of those videos I did. so I do encourage
you guys to do the minerals, and then to grow
all your food and especially if you guys have
pets or animals, grow the food for them using
the trace minerals, so that they can be healthier.I
mean as Dr. Wallach who's a, you know a veterinary,
and went to school for animal husbandry, you
know saw that they always would feed animals
trace mineral supplements in their feed.Why
don't we?From a young age, have trace mineral
supplements right? They are worth their weight
in something, instead of actually just going
in one end and coming out the other.
So that's what I want to talk about next.If
you guys aren't up to the point where you
guys are actually growing asignificant portion
of your food, and just want to ensure you
get the proper minerals.I want you guys
to eat foods that have high levels of trace
minerals in there.So aside from my home
grown rock dust, you know, soil humates, blooming
mineral, ocean solid, enhanced vegetables
that I grow.I also take some different products
such as seaweed powders, I take seaweed powders
almost every day. seaweed have a wide spectrum
of minerals, because in the oceans, they have
significantly more minerals, than most parts
of soil or of land soil.Depending on less
rain maybe, in one of the blue zones, and
that's probably one of the reasons why blue
zones people live so long. because they actually
have the trace minerals.But there's other
reasons as well.But aside from that, I also
take some supplementary minerals. and so the
ones that I've been taken recently are these
guys.so this is also this is the youngevity
brand and this is actually Dr. Wallach's product.This
is actually called the plant derived minerals.So
this is the liquid version, and I like this
a lot because actually there's no artificial
colors, flavors, sweeteners and let me tell
you, tastes like hell. If you're going to
drink, you're going to be like whoa. I mean,
I suppose it tastes better to me than alcohol,but
I don't drink.But has a strong flavor when
I drink, some reverse osmosis water after
drinking this straight up, which actually
I don't recommend for you guys.Actually
the water tasted sweet, and that's how bad
the minerals taste.So if you're going to
get these minerals that are liquid then I
do encourage you guys to maybe like mix them
in with some juice or something like that,
it will taste a lot better.But yeah, this
has up to seventy-six different minerals also,
that are listed on the back. and basically
a thing about these minerals unlike a Centrum
tablet or other minerals,these are actually
from plant derived minerals. So basically
these are plants that basically composted
thousands of years agoand basically they
put in a bottle. so the minerals are coming
from plants.Now if you don't like liquids,
like Josh doesn't like sipping liquids in
bottles, you guys could actually get the capsules.
so liquids or capsules and I've also taken
these capsules, these capsules are actually
in gelatin caps, so I don't like to take gelatin
caps, I don't like to take a lot of processed
things like that.So I actually open the
capsules up and put in my tongue.I was not
and that was another not so great idea that
I had recently. It actually fuzzed and bubbled
on my tongue andthat even tasted worse than
liquid. So I don't recommend doing that. maybe
mix the tablets in with a juice, once again
I would empty the contents of the capsule,
out of the capsule. or if you don't mind taking
some gelatin, just swallow the capsule whole,
while you're taking it with some juice and
the capsule will dissolve and you'll get the
minerals in you, and your body will absorb
them and get healthier because it.I mean,
I think overall Dr. Wallach looks great for
his age, you know I'm sure nobody does everything
exactly right, and I hope he eats his share
of fresh fruits and vegetables grown in rock
dust and soil humates enhanced and blooming
minerals and all that stuff. and just eats
the you know the majority of his food is plant
food, because those are the best food and
I mean that's why I got into gardening. and
the Greens are why I got into gardening, one
of the reasons is because the minerals. like
I want to get the trace minerals in me, I
don't want to have a mineral deficiency.You
know there's many different health challenges,
that can be caused by a mineral deficiency,
according to documented research that I have
seen.I will have an upcoming episode, actually
on some brand new fertilizers that may help
with certain conditions, that are formulated
with certain minerals that are known to be
deficient in individuals with certain conditions.So
I'm really looking forward to that episode
but in the meantime, right to keep your health,
to have your wealth which is your health,I
want you guys to supplement, you know, not
only yourselves but also your soils more importantly,
with the trace minerals. your plants will
be happier and in the end you could be happier
and I wish all of industry to simply do this.
it would not be that much more expensive to
start using rock dust, locally sourced rock
dust from different quarries and adding that
to the farmlands to increase their fertility,
increase the nutrition of America's foods.
and if America's not going to do that's great,
if you guys are from another country, hey
tell your ministry of agriculture and all
this stuff, to watch my video. and I want
you guys, whatever country you guys are in,
to start mineralizing your guys' foods. I
mean in some countries, they are actually
taking seaweed powders and bacon into bread,
and the health of the population is actually
increasing, because of this. and I want America
to be first in everything, but if there's
anyone whocoulddo it,I don't care who
does it, because I just want, you know the
world need to change. the world needs to start
remineralizing the soil, not only for the
soil health, not only for the people health
but for the planet health as well.So if
you guys want to pick up some of these mineral
products for the soil or the ones you want
to take internally,please check the link
down below this video, that will get you to
where you guys can order them. also be sure
to click the Subscribe button right down below,
to be notified by new and upcoming episodes
upcoming out about every three to four days,
you never know what I'll be talking about,
or what you'll be learning about my YouTube
gardening channel. also be sure to check my
past episodes, my past episodes are a wealth
of knowledge. I have over twelve hundred episodes
to date, teach you guys all aspects on how
to grow your own food at home. and be sure
like this video. that'llencourage me to
maybe hit up Dr. Wallach next time for another
interview and maybe you'll have a- some more
good questions for- so well once again, my
name is John Kohler with growingyourgreens.com.
We'll see you next time.And until then,
remember keep on growing.
All right.This is John Kohler with growingyourgreens.com
today with another exciting episode for you.
and I'm happy to be at the National heirloom
Expo. This is the world's Pure Food Fair.
You're going to learn more about them.